poursuit sans plus tarder sur ce même
dossier avec ferry de kerchove ancien
ambassadeur du canada et professeur à
l'école supérieure d'affaires publiques
et internationales de l'université
d'ottawa bonsoir monsieur de kerchove
toujours plaisir de s'entretenir avec
vous alors vous avez entendu
précédemment quelques-unes des analyses
notamment d'un ancien ambassadeur
henri-paul normandeau qui dit que la
porte finalement est grande ouverte pour
la libération des deux michael on y
reviendra à ça mais quelle lecture
faites vous de ces tout derniers
développements qu'est ce qui a bien pu
se produire qui était quel a été
l'élément déclencheur selon vous en
coulisses il ya deux éléments
premièrement je crois que la chine
elle-même en avait un petit peu
ras-le-bol de toute cette affaire qui ne
cessait de lui donner un portrait qui
s'ajoutaient ou portrait ouïghours et au
je crois que le deuxième point c'est le
dialogue entre baden et jean ping ou
véritablement ça a été mis sur la table
que j'admire de la part de john dryden
mais je crois que tout le monde voulait
en finir et cibler la pression montait
et le sort des 2 michael devenait de
plus en plus embarrassant pour la chine
alors je crois que c'est vraiment cette
pression mais il ya aussi effectivement
la relation étroite
canado-américaine ou byden avait promis
de faire quelque chose son secrétaire
d'état également et je crois
véritablement que c'est vous dis c'est
cette espèce de lassitude et en plus de
ça le malade ming voulait aussi rentrer
au pays et je crois que l'ensemble de
cette mesure et je crois qu'il ya aussi
un climat de tensions internationales
sur lequel monsieur byden voulait mettre
un peu la [ __ ] douce et tout en étant
toujours fixé sur la chine bryden
voulait aussi éviter d'être en en cible
est d'être en charge et si je puis dire
dans des petites affaires comme celle là
aux yeux de la politique internationale
oui on sent bien que ce dossier c'est
une mangue ou maïwenn joey et par le
fait même celui des deux mains cole est
interdite à toute une conjoncture
internationale le conflit qui s'enlise
en mer de chine ce baden qui essaient de
sang de s'en dépêtrer bref pour la suite
des choses pour les deux mains quo
jusqu'à quel point ça peut aller vite à
partir de ce moment si ça fait plus de
deux ans qui sont derrière les barreaux
je suis je suis très heureux de voir mon
ami henri paul normandin effet très
optimiste qui connaît la chine mieux que
moi j'ai tendance à dire que les chinois
ont maintenu au tout début de la sphère
que les deux cas étaient liés puis
progressivement il on y est et ce qui
fait que j'ai l'impression qu'ils vont
prendre un certain temps il ya deux
éléments d'abord ce pas mort lui a déjà
été jugé il a 11 ans de prison en israël
est extradé mais covering lui n'a pas
encore eu son jugement alors est ce que
les chinois vont accélérer la procédure
pour procéder exactement de la même
manière le juger et le condamner un x
années et on le renvoie en même temps
que se passe dehors au canada parce qu'à
ce moment là les chinois sur le plan
juridique ont fait ce qu'ils devaient
faire c'est-à-dire juger les deux
personnes il avait déjà insérée pour spa
worley l'extradition si je puis dire à
la fin de son de deux salles de son
emprisonnement mais ça c'est quelque
chose sur lequel le gouvernement chinois
peut en tout temps en tout bon sens
hamid diminuer la peine est renvoyé les
deux en même temps donc moi je vous
dirai ça va prendre plusieurs semaines
avant que c'est seulement que ça se
déroule je ne pense pas qu'on verra les
deux michael même que j'aime ci tentait
que j'aimerais tellement les voir ici
mais je pense que ça va prendre encore
un certain temps très bien soyons
patients mais bon il faut quand même
revenir sur sur le canada et ses
relations avec la chine dans tout ça
depuis longtemps le canada dans un
véritable étau entre la chine et les
états unis deux poids lourds de la
évidemment sur l'échiquier mondial en
quoi c'est ce dénouement qui est en
cours et qui s'accélère peut changer nos
relations avec le géant chinois je crois
que nous allons progressivement cessé
d'être les otages de nos deux au talent
si je puis dire parce que du moment
qu'ils soient libérés la donne et nous
elle ça va prendre un certain temps mais
nous avons quand même des intérêts
considérables
ma préoccupation est ce que les chinois
vont mettre des conditions à la
libération des 2 michael comme par
exemple que nous embrassions ou huawei
alors que tout le monde en veut plus à
cause des problèmes avec la chine je ne
pense pas c'est pour ça je pense il va
prendre un certain temps et je pense
qu'il va y avoir une véritable réflexion
ce qui est un peu près temps sur la
nature des relations qu'on va avoir avec
la chine n'oubliez pas que la vision
européenne et la vision américaine de la
relation avec les chine est très
différente les européens ont besoin du
marché chinois et vice versa ils sont
beaucoup plus prompts à commercer en
dépit de tous les problèmes que l'on a
sur le plan des droits de la personne
oui dit m
tandis que du côté des états unis le la
chine est véritablement le l'opposant
principal avec lequel on doit gérer à
laon le canada va devoir trouver si vous
voulez un sp2 conduit entre ces
différentes tendances est-ce qu'il se
ralliera davantage du côté européen tout
en prétendant au frais les américains
que nous tenons la dragée haute je pense
qu'il va y avoir une opération en
finesse est ce que notre gouvernement
est suffisamment sophistiquée pour le
faire ça je n'en sais rien je ne suis
pas confiant à 100% mais il ya trop
d'intérêts regardez simplement le nombre
d'étudiants chinois que nous avons
appuyé dans les dernières décennies au
canada qui renforce simule la capacité
de nos universités il ya tellement
d'éléments qui joue que je crois qu'il
va y avoir véritablement une
reproduction faite avec lenteur et et
avec quand même une certaine retenue
mais je pense que nous allons devoir
redécouvrir la chine à moins que
d'autres histoires sur vienne ce qui
n'est jamais akossi ce qui n'est jamais
impossible effectivement et on rappelle
dans tout ça dans le calendrier plus ou
moins immédiat la tenue des jeux
olympiques à pékin dans quelques mois et
bien sûr que les chinois vont vouloir
dissiper des histoires qui pourrait leur
nuire à travers tout ça ça fait merci
tout à fait je courais allez-y vous en
prie le monde après je crois que la
question allait vivre un sort bien de la
soulever parce que là le canada n'aura
plus beaucoup deux raisons à part les
ouïghours et autre chose mais la sphère
des deux michael est elle là n'a pu
saillants si je puis dire je pense
qu'effectivement nous allons
probablement le retrouver aux jeux
olympiques et nous nous irons gagné la
médaille d'or au hockey
espèrons le respect et tout ça sera
diffusée évidemment sur les autres je le
rappelle de radio canada diffuseur
officiel merci beaucoup aux ferries de
kerchove avec plaisir prochaine pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici rdi